وخلاصة حديثهم الناتو والاتحاد
الاوروبي. اتركونا وشأننا. نريد
سبيلا. ليصرخ المتظاهرون نحن
نعاقب انفسنا ولم نعاقب روسيا.
الناس في فرنسا يبيعون هدايا عيد
الميلاد بسبب الغلاء المعيشي
طوابير الجوع امام بنوك توزيع
الطعام وسط ازمة ارتفاع الاسعار
كما تعانون انتم. اوروبا تختنق.
الوضع الاوروبي يزداد سوءا يوما
للتعبير عن الكبير من فواتير
الطاقة. بل ذهبوا الى حد
مباشرة مع موردي الغاز ومنهم
روسيا. ليخرج رئيس وزراء المجر
فيكتور اوربان قائلا ان العقوبات
المفروضة ضد روسيا قد تجبر
المطالبة باسقاط العقوبات
المفروضة على موسكو. وابرام عقود
الحاشدة اجتاحت لتشي. وانتفض
الاف النمساويين في فيينا
حلا فنحن نعيش من اجل دفع فواتير
الكهرباء والغاز. المظاهرات
شوارع برلين وروائح العطور تختفي
من شوارع باريس. لتحل محلها
الغاز الروسي. تدهور الاقتصاد
البريطاني لتصبح واحدة من افقر
الروسية الاوكرانية التي لا
ترحم. لتتهم الحكومة البريطانية
تأتيهم من كل حدب وصوب. ازمة
كورونا وازمة نقص العمالة
بل انهم يرفضون المساعدات
لاوكرانيا وهم الاحوج لها.
الحجري. لقد عادوا مئات السنين
الى الوراء بسبب انقطاع طاقة
لتقنين الغاز الطبيعي واعادة
تشغيل محطات توليد الطاقة بالفحم
المانيا اكبر الاقتصادات
الاوروبية. السلطات تعد خططا
بالمساعدات من اوكرانيا. فطوابير
طويلة امام بنوك طعام. سبعة
مهلا. وسط الازمة الاقتصادية
التي تعصف بالبلاد لندن تنوي
الشعب البريطاني لاكن وجبتين او
اقل يوميا عن اي تقشف نتحدث لكن
الحديدية. وان مرضت فلن تنقذك
سيارة الاسعاف. وان وصلت الى
لن تجد مواصلات فقد اضرب اكثر من
اربعين الف عامل في شبكة السكك
بعد يوم. والسبب تداعيات الحرب
الروسية الاوكرانية. فقد اصبح
للحصول على بعض الطعام. وبالقرب
من فرنسا في اسبانيا تزداد
على الخروج من الاتحاد الاوروبي
ولو عاد بنا الزمن لن نصوت
يعيشون في رفاهية مطلقة. الغذاء
متوفر والطاقة تصلهم عبر صنابير
لاوكرانيا لعام الفين وثلاثة
وعشرين. والشعب يصرخ نحن اولى
دولار. ورئيس الوزراء يقترب من
اعلان حزمة مساعدات جديدة
زيادة ميزانية الدفاع الخاصة بها
بنحو مليار وثمانمائة مليون
اليوم على شفا مجاعة وكانه دولة
نامية. مشاكل بالجملة والمصائب
اقتصادية حادة في اهم قطاعاتها
الطب والمواصلات وعلى رأسها
والزبائن ويلوذون بالفرار. فاي
حال اليه بريطانيا العظمى. وبسبب
الشباب تسرق متجر مواد غذائية في
وضح النهار امام عمال المتجر
الاقتصادي بدأ ينفد والشعب
يختنق. وللمرة الاولى ينتقد
ممسكة بدفة القيادة ومحملة
بالوعود. محاولة الهروب من
الحرارة زادت حدة العاصفة
السياسية التي ضربت حكومة جونسون
الانجليز. ارتفعت اسعار فواتير
الغاز والكهرباء ليقرر البعض ترك
بزملائه اذا ما استمرت. الضرائب
تلتهم الاجور ونسبة التضخم بلغت
مستويات تاريخية. اصبحت الحياة
اليومية مكلفة جدا في بلاد
تحتل الهند. واليوم رجل من اصول
هندية بريطانيا. فماذا انت فاعل
ليحطمونها. تضامنا مع ذوي الدخل
المنخفض قائلين لا يمكننا ان نقف
الاجور المنخفضة والظروف
المعيشية وارتفاع الاسعار لارقام
خدودهم هنا الممرضين. القصة
باختصار الحكومة مصابة بجلطة
جونسون ليصعد ريش سوناك ذو
الاصول الهندية. فيا لسخرية
صندوق الدولي ميزانية بريطانيا
بشكل واضح. ليحث الحكومة على
البريطانيين لتستمر نسبة التضخم
في الارتفاع. وتصبح الاعلى بين
اليزابيث التي استمرت سبعين
عاما. بدأ العام بتحديات
يا حفيد غاندي? كان عام بريطانيا
الساخنة رغم قساوة البرد لا
البلدان تقدما في العالم. لينهال
الناشطون ضربا على محطات الوقود
سلطتها بعد اقل من خمسين يوما
لتخر حكومتها سريعة بجانب حكومة
ادخنة مسيلة الدموع. ايطاليا
اصبحت البيتزا لمن استطاع اليها
روسية. انتم في العصر الحجري يا
سادة. براكين الغضب تتفجر في
العاصفة. التضخم الاقتصادي
يستحوذ على مساحة اكبر والاكسجين
بقيمتها بعضا من الغذاء. وطلاب
الجامعات يقفون في طوابير طويلة
الحادة التي تعصف بهم. الازمة
الاقتصادية طرقت اوسع ابواب
على البريطاني. ارتفعت الاسعار
ووصلت نسبة التضخم الى ستة
سياسية غير مسبوقة. فما الذي
يجري في بريطانيا العظمى? وصل
للتاريخ في بريطانيا على مستويات
مختلفة. ثلاثة رؤساء. اربعة
اقتصادية. فبريطانيا تحاول
التعافي من تبعات كوفيد تسعة عشر
التضخم الى اعلى مستوياته منذ
عقود. انتهت حقبة الملكة
للانفصال عن اوروبا. لا تقلقوا
يا اصدقاء فالاتحاد يعاني ايضا
اوروبا على الركوع على ركبتي.
دول اوروبا الغربية بعد ان كانت
واحدة من اقوى الاقتصادات في
العالم وليس في اوروبا فقط. لسان
حال الانجليز يقول نحن نادمون
فلاديمير بوتين انه هو السبب في
اوضاعه. وبعد ان كان البريطانيون
الاوروبي نتحدث. وللقصة بقية.
الفين واثنان وعشرون هو عام
البلد الذي كان يعد احد اقوى
الدول العظمى في العالم. ها هو
في البلاد. والاقتصاد جاثم على
ركبتيه يلطم خديه. الدولة التي
البريطانيون بشبابهم وشيوخهم
ينتظرون المساعدات. الفقر اصبح
كانت وجهة العرب الاولى للسياحة
والمال والاعمال. ها هم اليوم
وتخبطات الحكومات المتعاقبة
وارتفاع تكاليف طاقة والحرب
للحصول على بعض لترات الوقود
وحتى المواطنين. نعم.
تشهدها البلاد. ووصلت الحرارة
الى درجة مئوية. ومع زيادة
لتسقط حكومة جونسون سريعة وتقدم
استقالتها. وتصعد ديزات راس
مجموعة الدول السبع الكبرى. جاءت
اشهر الصيف محملة بموجة حارة لم
ملايين بريطاني لا يجدون ما
يأكلونه بسبب ارتفاع الاسعار.
فلكية. هنا تتفجر ثورة
الاضرابات. فاذا كنت في بريطانيا
الطيران. والسبب الاجور المنخفضة
والاسعار المرتفعة التي ارغمت
المستشفى فلن ترى الا وجوه
ملائكة الرحمة واضعين كفوفهم على
في هذه الاثناء عاصفة اخرى. هنا
بدأت العواصف تهز مركب الساسة
واثنين من عشرة في المائة. ويا
له من تضخم ارهق المملكة. لتبدأ
لاوكرانيا وتأزمت اسواق النفط
والاسواق العالمية والعاصفة تهب
يحدث؟ المملكة التي لا تغيب عنها
الشمس. ها هي اليوم في ظلام
مكتوفي الايدي. حتى ان الشباب
اتجهوا للسرقة. وهذه مجموعة من
في عز الشتاء القارص ونحن لسنا
في ادغال افريقيا انما في اكثر
الاقتصادية لتأتي طامة الكبرى.
في فبراير بدأ الغزو الروسي
الحلوق وتحجرت الالسن. من اداروا
الدنيا دهرا دارت الدنيا يوما
الاقدار ويا لخباثة عقارب
الساعة. بالامس كانت بريطانيا
التراجع عنها. فضلا عن انتقادات
داخلية حادة. دافعت تراس لتسليم
الملكة اليزابيث. المظاهرات
تشتعل. الشعب غاضب. ما الذي
نهاية له. الاضرابات التي تشل
البلاد قد تدفع ريش سوناك للحاق
يفرون فلماذا كل ذلك يا هؤلاء?
يجيب المواطنون نحن نادمون. لقد
خدعتنا حكومتنا. فعن اي حرب واي
اوضاع نتحدث. عن الانتحار
وزراء مالية. ثلاثة وزراء داخلية
في اقل من شهرين تم تغييرهم.
فوق رؤوسهم. سياراتهم في طوابير
طويلة تنافس الدول النامية.
دامس. الرؤساء يتبدلون والوزراء
يرحلون. انتهت الاعذار وجفت
هاي انت. ماذا تفعل؟ الذنب ليس
ذنب محطة الوقود. بل ذنب احفاد